on va passer au débat de ce club on va
revenir sur la décision rendue hier
Samia par la Cour de justice éric
dupontéti a donc été relaxé est-ce que
pour autant ça éteint la polémique au
sein de pour sur son maintien au sein du
gouvernement alors plus ou moins Orian
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il reste en
poste au ministère de la justice
puisqu'il a été relaxé hier par la Cour
de Justice de la République après son
procès pour soupçon de prise illégale
d'intérêt la Cour a donc estimé qu'il
n'y avait pas eu d'intention de se
venger dans sa décision d'ordonner des
enquêtes sur plusieurs magistrats qui je
rappelle avait été critiqué par le
ministre lorsqu'il était encore avocat
la Cour l'a donc jugé non coupable elle
n'a pas suivi les réquisitions du
procureur général qui réclamaé un an de
prison avec surcis pour Éric duponoriti
il reste en poste mais son procès laisse
des traces estime le Parti socialiste
qui s'interroge je cite il est désormais
établi que le garde des saau marque une
hostilité à l'égard de la magistrature
et qu'il s'estime victime d'une vindicte
comment peut-il sereinement assumer ses
fonctions c'est un extrait d'un
communiqué hier publié hier par le Parti
socialiste et qui pose une question
simple Éric Dupont Moretti peut-il
rester le ministre de tutelle des
magistrats à qui il s'est opposé dans ce
procès il a tenté de répondre lui-même
hier soir sur France 2 regardez je veux
tourner la
page même si c'était quelque chose de
douloureux et je veux reprendre le cours
ordinaire de mon travail je n'ai jamais
été en guerre avec qui que ce
soit et on va revenir vous allez on va
on va continuer les les les réactions
politiques pardon Sam bien mais sur
cette question que pose le Parti
socialiste et à laquelle a répondu hier
Éric Dupont Moretti ça bien le rappeler
c'est la première fois qu'un garde des
saut en exercice est jugé par la Cour de
Justice de la République est-ce que du
coup ça pose la question de l'après et
de comment va-t-il travailler désormais
avec les
magistrats pas pour moi ça c'est une
décision politique qu'il appartient au
présid président de la République à la
première ministre et au Gard des sur
luimême de régler son maintien au
gouvernement absolument donc qui ne
regarde pas le juriste que je suis ni le
membre de l'association anticorps que je
suis starto sur la manière dont cette
décision rendu hier par la Cour de
Justice de la République peut être perçu
par l'opinion publique est-ce que ça
peut générer un risque d'in
comompréhension je pense qu'il y a
plusieurs mécaniques d'opinion qui
doivent être dissocié pour apporter
plusieurs réponses d'abord la première
c'est effectivement une forme de
méfiance envers le personnel politique
une perte de confiance à toutes les
études d'opinion le montrent 69 % des
Français estim que les dirigeants
politiques sont corrompus 77 % estiment
qu'ils sont même déconnectés de la
réalité qui servent leur propres
intérêts qui va alimenter une deuxième
mécanique c'est cette perte de confiance
il faut le dire aussi dans notre système
politique et démocratique he 74 % des
Français estiment que la démocratie en
France fonctionne mal mais avant tout et
peut-être être surtout je pense au au
cœur de de ces débats il y a cette idée
que le ou la politique dans ce qu'elle
incarne dans ce qu'elle fait est à la
fois immorale mais aussi impuissante il
y a une forme de valité du vote
aujourd'hui qui s'exprime très
clairement donc je pense que cette cette
affaire cette actualité elle vient
alimenter ces trois constats euh le la
défiance qui est de plus en plus
importante le côté effectivement manque
de confiance et de probité du personnel
politique qui s'ajoute à cette sorte
d'impuissance de l'action politique a
changé le le cours des choses et le
quotidien des des Français on va y
revenir hein parce que la question de
son maintient au gouvernement Sami l'a
dit s'est posé Éric Dupont Moretti en
tout cas il a la confiance d'Emmanuel
Macron oui he l'Élysée qui avait choisi
de le maintenir en poste pendant toute
la durée de son procès n'a pas
officiellement réagi mais on le sait
Emmanuel Macron a reçu Éric Dupont
moriti hier juste après l'annonce de sa
relaxe ellisabeth borne qui avait
affirmé qu'il devrait quitter le
gouvernement en cas de condamnation
s'est exprimé sur X anciennement Twitter
je cite le garde des saau va pouvoir
continuer à mener son action au sein de
l'quip équipe gouvernementale au service
des Français je m'en réjouis a écrit la
première ministre c'est un soulagement
on sait pour la majorité présidentiel
regardez la réaction de François patria
chef de fil des sénateurs macroniste au
micro de Quentin calm il a une règle
simple on est condamné on s'en va on est
relaxé on peut rester il a subi un
procès difficile douloureux avec de
nombreuses attaques à travers eux
beaucoup de médias particulier je le dis
je le dis aussi ici et qu'il puisse
aujourd'hui en sortir blanchi c'est son
qui est aujourd'hui est rétabli et c'est
sa fonction qui doit être renforcée et
au-delà du cas personnel d'Éric dupontti
Sam bien ce procès a relancer le débat
sur la légitimité de la Cour de Justice
de la République oui dès l'annonce de la
relaxe du ministre de la Justice la
France insoumise a demandé la
suppression de la Cour de Justice de la
République c'est la seule institution
habilitée à juger un ministre en
exercice pour des faits commis en tant
que ministre c'est d'ailleurs la
première fois que c'est arrivé cette
cour elle est composée je le rappelle de
12 parlementaires et de trois magistrats
les politiques peuvent-ils juger
d'autres politiques et bien à gauche la
réponse et non regardez la réaction de
Yen brossa sur notre antenne je pense
qu'il faut en finir avec la CJR et en
finir avec une forme de justice
d'exception qui ne correspond pas à ce
qu'on attend de la justice dans notre
pays qui doit pouvoir juger tout le
monde de la même manière Paul cass
est-ce que ça pose la question de la la
pertinence de cette Cour de Justice de
la République avant de parler de sa
suppression bien évidemment et cette
question elle se pose indépendamment du
sens de la décision qui a été rendue à
garde de Monsieur Dupont Moretti qu'il
était relaxé ou condamné de toute façon
il y a un problème structurel et ce
problème structurel il est ancien c'est
pas parce que aujourd'hui l'opposition
réclame à nouveau la tête le président
de la République a été au Congrès de
Versailles et qu'il a explicitement
indiqué que la CJR était une juridiction
de l'exception qui devait disparaître
donc il y a un quasi consensus pour dire
que la CJR n'est pas est une anomalie
républicaine et démocratique et tout à
l'heure Steven parlait de confiance et
bien on ne peut pas faire confiance à la
CGR pour juger de manière impartiale des
ministres des membres du gouvernement à
forurri quand il s'agit comme en
l'espèce de ministre en exercice
pourquoi parce que le la CGR est composé
essentiellement de parlementaires qui
ont une vision partiale c'est c'est
c'est normal c'est structurel ils ont
une opinion politique ils connaissent le
ministre une vision partiale du litige
sur lequel ils ont à se prononcer donc
il y a un préjugé un préjugé pour ou un
préjugé contreà ce sont des
parlementaires de tout bord majorité
opposition et que le préjugé soit pour
ou contre ça n'a pas d'importance la
difficulté tient de fait qu'il y a au
départ un préjugé et ça c'est
inacceptable et c'est ce qui porte
atteinte à la confiance que nous devons
avoir dans nos
institutions il y a une atteinte à la
confiance avec cette Cour de Justice de
la République oui je pense que ce qui
vient d'être dit est assez juste quand
on pose la question à l'opinion publique
sur les sentiments que procure P quand
on leur propose de parler de la
politique le premier mot qui arrive en
tête c'est méfiance et cette méfiance
elle tend à se transformer à une forme
de défiance et ça je pense que c'est
extrêmement important de l'avoir en tête
parce qu'on se pose régulièrement la
question de comment redonner confiance
en notre système démocratique en la
décision politique cette affaire là elle
vient impacter cette cette confiance là
inévitablement et cette incompréhension
vous disiez très justement de cette de
cette décision finalement elle va
peut-être assez peu impacter
l'opinion sur Éric Dupont Moretti mais
enfin je pense qu'elle alimente un
constat qui est quand même assez négatif
sur l'état aujourd'hui du fonctionnement
de nos de nos institutions et donc de la
confiance que l'on a en notre personnel
politique dans un contexte en plus
marqué il faut le dire par un
fonctionnement de la justice qui est
aussi là très décrié par l'opinion
publique un plus de 7 Français sur 10
estime que ce système fonctionne mal
donc une demande aussi de sévérité
d'autorité et donc une institution comme
ça hybride dont on ne saurait pas
vraiment qu'elle serait à la fois la
légitimité et effectivement la la la
pertinence pour juger un ministre va
laisser sûrement des sûrement des traces
Paul est-ce que pour vous il faut la
réformer cette Cour de Justice de la
République avec peut-être plus de
transparence ou est-ce qu'il faut
carrément la supprimer la transparence
ça va rien changer parce que il y a que
le vote qui est secret le vote sur le
délibéré qui est secret pour le reste
les auditions étaient publiques ce qui
est certain c'est qu'il faut supprimer
la Cour de Justice de la République
comme ça avait été proposé en 2012 en 2
17 il faut la supprimer pour la raison
que les ministres doivent être jugés par
une juridiction ordinaire pour qu'il n'y
ait pas de doute sur la partialité ou
l'impartialité des juges comme ça peut
être le cas aujourd'hui pour la CJR et
évidemment avec un filtre préalable
parce que l'action gouvernementale doit
être préservée il ne s'agit pas que tout
un chacun saisisse une juridiction
contre l'action de tout le gouvernement
ça serait impossible il doit y avoir des
filtres mais les juges ordinaires
doivent pouvoir ir se saisir de l'action
gouvernementale mais on a Laurent
jacobelli qui était notre invité le
porte-parole du rassemblement national
lui dit qu' qu'il était pas pour la
suppression de la Cour de Justice de la
République parce que c'est exposé les
ministres au pouvoir des juges alors
d'abord le pouvoir des juges en lui-même
il doit pas être craint c'est la
séparation des pouvoirs que un pouvoir
doit être contrôlé par un autre pouvoir
donc en soi être contrôlé par des juges
c'est normal c'est même bienvenu
simplement il ne faut pas que les les
juridiqu puisse être
saisie n'importe quel moment contre
n'importe quelle action de des ministres
donc il doit avoir un filtre et ce
filtre il est prévu dans le projets qui
avait été mis en place en 2012 sous
François Hollande et en 2017 sous
Emmanuel Macron il avait un filtre qui
était chargé de trier les requêtes avant
que une juridiction se prononce sur le
bien fondé de la demande voilà et on va
on va écouter ce qu'en pense Gérard
larch le président du Sénat il était
invité ce matin de la matinale LCI lui
défend la place du politique on l'écoute
aujourd'hui la Cour de Justice de la
République est une institution qui
fonctionne la décision politique c'est
une décision complexe pour un ministre
et avoir des juges dans une cour de
justice de la République qui connaissent
comment on contextualise une décision
politique et bien je crois que c'est
utile et d'ailleurs un certain nombre de
pays ont un système comparable au nôtre
pa non je peux pas du tout suivre cette
opinion euh d'abord il y a pas du tout
beaucoup de pays qui ont un système
comparable au nôtre avec une juridiction
d'exception politique pour juger les
ministres en exercice première chose et
et seconde chose ce que dit le président
Larcher il dit ceci il dit un ministre
doit être jugé par des politiques parce
que les politiques comprennent le
ministre mais mais on ne veut pas de ça
c'est c'est précisément l'entre soi qui
porte atteinte à la confiance dans la
justice il faut que les juges tranchent
de manière impartiale imparti partiale
l'action du ministre devait être évaluée
de manière impartielle par des juges qui
sont tout à fait à même de savoir s'il a
commis ou pas un délit de prise illégale
d'intérêt sans qu'il soit besoin d'être
parlementaire sur ce point-là ouis et on
précise juste que la Cour de Justice de
la République elle juge les ministres
sur des faits commis dans l'exercice de
leur fonction de ministre c'est pour ça
qu'Olivier du SOP lui est jugé devant
une justice classique parce que c'est
des faits même s'il est ministre parce
que c'est des faits qui lui étent
reproché alors qu'il était encore
masument juste St
est-ce que il y a un risque en en
jugeant les ministres devant une justice
classique he je met des guillemets de
les exposer et que du coup il soit plus
frileux dans leur action politique avec
peut-être une moindre prise de
décision ça ce serait ser très compliqué
de répondre à cette à cette question sur
l'expertise que que je représente qui
est celle de du coup sur un
affaiblissement du politique absolument
je trouve que ce qui est assez important
de soulever c'est que les Français sont
dans une posture un peu ambivalente d'un
côté effectiv ent ils estiment que
l'action politique ne porte pas assez
ses fruits dans le le le quotidien donc
la politique ne change pas la vie la vie
des gens et de l'autre côté il y a une
forme de sévérité on l'a dit qui est
générée par cette méfiance cette
défiance envers le personnel politique à
chaque élection on se pose la question
de comment rendre ce système
démocratique politique plus comment dire
plus vivant avec une confiance plus
assumée de la part de la part des
français quand on leur pose la question
des réformes par exemple des
institutions
pour rendre un peu de confiance ce qui
est assez intéressant et je trouve que
c'est un indicateur assez frappant de ce
que l'on dit c'est que toutes les
mesures qui arrivent en tête ce n'est
pas du tout des mesures qui amèneraient
les Français aux urnes mais plus des
mesures qui viendraient sanctionner le
politique c'est-à-dire la possibilité de
révocation des élus l'interdiction de
faire plus de trois mandats et cetera et
cetera donc on voit bien le ces
différentes mécaniques d'opinion qui se
qui se qui s'exprime et qui s'alimente à
la fois la méfiance à la fois cette
impuissance du politique et à la fois
effectivement cette perte de confiance
qu'on a aujourd'hui envers envers nos
dirigeants al une des propositions qui a
été faite depuis qu'on connaît la
décision de la CGR c'est une proposition
de transparencie internationale qui
propose de créer un poste de déontologue
du gouvernement qui serait un peu chargé
d'examiner les potentiel conflit
d'intérêt à chaque nomination d'un
nouveau ministre est-ce que ça pourrait
être une solution satisfaisante bon on
peut toujours créer des postes
supplémentaires c'est très bien ici on a
quand même une autorité qui existe
s'appelle la Haute autorité pour la
transparence sur la vie publique
qui a alerté le ministre sur ses
conflits d'intérêts elle l'a alerté le 7
octobre alors que la situation de
conflit d'intérêt s'est cristallisée le
18 septembre 2020 donc il y a déjà et on
a une autre autorité qui s'appelle le
secrétariat général du gouvernement qui
est chargé précisément d'alerter le le
ministre ou tout l'ensemble du
gouvernement sur les éventuelles
irrégularités qui pourraent être commis
donc on a déjà tout ce qu'il faut par
ailleurs le garde des saau lui-même est
un pénaliste chevronné l'article 432 12
du code pénal qui prohibbe la prise
illégale d'intérêt il l'a pas découvert
au moment de son procès donc il sait il
savait déjà ce qu'était la prise
illégale d'intérêt avant d'entrer en
fonction heureusement donc on a déjà
suffisamment de de de garde fou de
barrière la probité c'est aussi une
éducation et je ne crois pas qu'une
institution supplémentaire même si elle
est pas mal venue pourra disons
satisfaire cette exigence de déontologie
personnelle qui doit animer chaque
membre du gouvernement un mot sur Éric
dupontéti hein sur sa personnalité Éric
duponti Samiel disait soutenu par
Emmanuel Macron qui a maintenu au
gouvernement malgré sa mise en examen
SARD quel est le regard des Français
aujourd'hui sur Éric dupupon morétier
alors nous dans No baromètrre d'opinion
notamment qu' le fait avec vos vos
confrères du Figaro on voit que depuis
la réélection d'Emmanuel Macron la
tendance est plutôt à la baisse en terme
de code d'avenir et de code de confiance
he il perd à peu près 6 points depuis la
réélection du du président de la
République donc on voit alors c'est une
dynamique qui est pas singulière à Eric
tupononetti hein c'est plutôt partagé
par l'ensemble des membres du
gouvernement qui ont été reconduit pour
le pour le deè 2ème quinquena second
quinena mais ce qui est vrai c'est que
cette confiance elle diminue après et je
pense que c'est aussi intéressant de
s'interroger c'est que l'action d'Éric
Dupont méti est pour l'instant assz
inaudible alors qu'il se prévout quand
même d'avoir eu trois budgets à la
hausse pour le ministère de la Justice
la création de 10000 postes
supplémentaires et pourtant et je disais
tout à l'heure plus de 7 Français sur 10
estime que la justice fonctionne mal
c'est l'une des institutions on a le
moins confiance avec une perte de
confiance extrêmement importante hein
c'est plus 10 points en perte de
confiance sur les C dernières années
donc le constat il il doit nous alerter
au-delà de la personne d'Éric Dupont
Moretti c'est le fonctionnement de notre
justice qui est incarné là par ce par ce
ministre qui est déstabilisé qu'il
faudra quand même relever mais comment
vous expliquez parce que Erric du pont
Moretti vous me dites hein c'est une
personnalité qui est quand même
identifiée par les Français pourquoi du
coup son action est-elle si invisible
bah c'est compliqué de je pense dans ce
contexte là on l'a vu déjà sur le
premier quinquena un contexte de crise
qui a évidemment balayé un certain
nombre de d'actions politiques le début
du deuxème quinena était aussi marqué
par l'entrée enfin par la guerre en
Ukraine on a eu la crise inflationniste
donc dans ce je dirais dans ce contexte
très saturé il a été compliqué et
au-delà des r pouromti pour un ensemble
de ministre de porter leur action au
devant au devant de la scène vous avez
raison de le dire aussi éc dupti c'est
le ministre qui a toujours été
sortant à chaque romanimement mais qui a
toujours été confirmé donc ça prouve
bien que le lien entre le Président de
la République et son Gard saau est assez
est assez étroit maintenant je pense que
les Français le savent il y a une
attente très importante sur la question
judiciaire ça ces attentes là il va
falloir y répondre au détriment sinon
d'une perte de confiance qui va
continuer à à se prononcer dans les
années qui viennent et à mon sens c'est
un risque que nous pouvons pas prendre
ouais il y a le risque d'une perte de
confiance Paul c le risque d'une perte
de confiance il résulte de ce qui s'est
passé c'est-à-dire du fait qu'un
ministre est jugé par des parlementaires
et par ailleurs que un autre ministre en
fonction Olivier dusopt fait
actuellement l'objet d'une procédure
devant les juridiction ordinaire et
c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est le
parquet national financier qui porte
l'accusation contre Olivier dusop qui
dit que c ce procès porte atteinte à la
confiance que doivent que les Français
doivent avoir dans leur responsable
politique il y a par ailleurs le fait
que vous l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure
Orian que jérô kusac souhaite revenir
sur le devant de la scène politique ce
qui est par ailleurs parfaitement s
droit donc ces trois événements dans la
semaine conjugué sont disons pte une une
image globalement négative effectivement
de de de ce qu'est la la responsabilité
politique jérô kaaiza qu'on devrait
entendre dans dans quelques secondes
Paul Cassia le rappelé il y a eu ce
procès d'Éric du pomti il y a
actuellement Olivier dusop qui est jugé
mais on le disait pour des faits qui ne
sont pas liés avec son ministère qui
sont des faits antérieurs à l'époque où
il était est-ce que du coup le
gouvernement vis-à-vis des Français a
une image qui est écornée avec ses
affaires alors je pense que le
gouvernement n'a pas eu à à voir
l'ensemble de ces actualités pour avoir
une image écornée la confiance sur
gouvernement aujourd'hui c'est de 26 %
c'est l'un des scorses les plus faibles
enregistrés au niveau européen pour vous
donner un ordre d'idée on est à 46 % en
Allemagne on est même à plus de 30 % en
Italie donc on est vraiment sur une
confiance dans le gouvernement qui est
assez faible je pense que ces actualités
là elles vont pas du tout en leur en
leur faveur mais elle fragilise
effectivement cette cette action
gouvernementale aujourd'hui ouis on va
terminer par Jérôme kausac vous en
parliez on va l'écouter Jérôme kusac je
le rappelle Jérôme kusac qui est
l'ancien ministre socialiste qui a été
condamné pour faute fiscale et qui
revient en politique il ne s'interdit
pas d'ailleurs de briguer un nouveau
mandat on va l'écouter il était l'invité
ce matin de Sud Radio et pour lui son
retour n'est pasim
Morel j'ai été condamné je n'ai pas
discuté Laem
je n'en avais d'ailleurs pas les moyens
j'ai purgé ma
peine je me suis
tue cette peine purgée toutes les peines
étant
purgées il n'est pas contestable il ne
peut il ne peut pas mêtre contesté le
fait que je suis redevenu un citoyen
comme les
autres je n'ai pas évidemment plus de
droit qu'un autre mais je n'en ai pas
moins Paul CIA vous entendez Jérôme KAC
on le rappelle vous êtes vice-président
d'anticors est-ce que ce retour en
politique de Jérôme kusac ça sonne comme
un échec pour vous pas du tout euh
Jérôme causac a payé sa dette pénale à
la société comme il le dit euh il est
juridiquement en droit de se présenter à
quelque élection qu'il souhaite après
c'est lui qui met le débat sur le
terrain de la moralité c'est lui-même
qui se place sur le terrain de la
moralité mais la moralité c'est un
concept
subjectif il a il porte en lui-même une
image négative parce que chacun sait
qu'il a été ministre des Finances chargé
de lutter en faveur de la probilité
publique alors qu'il a menti devant la
représentation nationale donc se plaçant
sur le terrain de la morité moralité il
donne les armes pour se faire battre
est-ce que l'image qu'il véhicule est
celle que nous attendons de nos
représentants politiques bon c'est à
chacun et à chacune de de répondre à
cette question moi j'ai mon opinion
personnelle mais chacune et chacun est à
même d'avoir la sienne start est-ce que
vous avez l'opinion des des Français sur
ce sujet le le deuxième sentiment qui
qui qui arrive du coup en deème position
quand on leur demande ce que ce que
représente la politique pour vous c'est
dégoût donc vous voyez a méfiance et
dégoût je je suis très mal placé pour
représenter aujourd'hui ce que pensent
les Français ou l'opinion en général sur
Jérôme kusac mais il est vrai quand même
que cette affaire là je pense qu'elle
qu'elle va nuire encore peut-être à
l'image aujourd'hui de du fonctionnement
politique ce qui ne veut absolument pas
dire que les Français se désintéressent
à la politique et à la chose publique
c'est pour ça qu'il y a une attente et
c'est pour ça qu'il y a un enjeu
fondamental sur ces questions là merci
merci à tous les deux si vous voulez
bien rester avec nous on va regarder
avec Samia ce qui à la une de nos
quotidiens
[Musique]
régionaux Sam on commence par une bonne
nouvelle puisque la France va de nouveau
accueillir les Jeux olympiques ce sera
les goivers 2030 et la presse régionale
s'en réjouit oui c'est gagné c'estcl le
Dauphiné le Comité international
olympique n'a retenu qu'une seule
candidature celle des Alpes françaises
pour les jeux d'hivers 2030 touchous
vers les gios titre Le Républicain les
jeux sont fait renchéris Nice ce matin
Nice qui devrait accueillir les épreuves
de patinage et de hoy entre autres les
autres sites sont tous répartis sur deux
régions la région PACA et la région
aunrenalpe plus à l'ouest la nouvelle
mosquée danger se fait toujours attendre
les fidèles pris dehors raconte ce matin
la une du Courrier de l'Ouest la mosquée
danger est trop petite pour accueillir
tout le monde résultat chaque vendredi
les musulmans pratiquant de la métropole
bien ils posent leur tapis sur un
parking voir autour dans l'herbe ou dans
la boue la construction d'une nouvelle
mosquée est très attendue mais elle est
à l'arrêt par manque de fond faut-il
accepté son rachat par le Maroc pour
acheter les travaux la question fait
débat et c'est à lire ce matin dans le
Courrier de l'Ouest ubert débarque à
Dijon oui c'est à la une du bien public
ce matin les habitants de Dijon peuvent
désormais commander une course VTC c'est
via la plateforme uber la société
américaine a décidé de s'implanter dans
la capitale des duc parce que dit-elle
la demande était forte S5000 connexions
en 2023 en réalité ce sont surtout des
touristes qui ont déjà l'habitude
d'utiliser uber dans leur ville
d'origine on finit par une touche sucrée
la tarte tatin fait la une du Berry
Républicain oui tout le monde la croit
normande mais elle est solognote elle
vient donc de Sologne la tarte tatin
fait partie du patrimoine culinaire de
Lamote bevvron dans Loir etcher une
vérité s'est rétabli dans un
documentaire l'histoire renversante
forcément de la tarte tatin sera
diffusée dimanche à 20h15 sur TV tour et
vous pourrait y apprendre la véritable
origine de ce dessert caramélisé qui
contrairement à la légende n'est pas né
d'une erreur de recette
on a mis à mal plein de légendes ce
matin sur la tarte ttin du coup merci
Samia merci beaucoup on regarde vos
livres Paul CCIA la République en miette
c'est aux éditions libre et solidaire si
vous voulez nous en dire un mot vous
avez 10 secondes non écoutez c'était un
constat que en fait la France n'allait
pas très très bien à l'époque selon moi
et je suis pas sûr qu'elle ait beaucoup
mieux aujourd'hui et votre livre écrit
avec Frédéric dab qu'on connait bien ici
he se la fracture c'est aux éditions Les
Arènes merci beaucoup à tous les deux
merci d'avoir été avec nous merci Samia
merci à tous de nous avoir suivi
prochain rendez-vous à 18h Thomas H sens
public et nous on se retrouve demain
très bonne
journée